(In theaters everywhere tonight.)
JON JON
Okay, let's get you ready to fight!
SHANG-CHI
Wait, what?
JON JON
We're a multi-platform global operation.
Every fight livestreamed
on the dark web.
Thousands of viewers
placing bets as we speak.
This is gonna take
your brand to a whole new level!
SHANG-CHI
Think there's been some sort of confusion.
KATY
I like your spike face.
JON JON
Usually, you gotta fight your way
to central ring. But a viral star
like you, front of the line, baby!
SHANG-CHI
I'm not here to fight anybody.
Ok? I'm looking
for my sister, Xu Xialing?
[Crowd cheers]
[Fighter grunts]
JON JON
Never heard of her.
We just lost a fighter at the
last minute, so you get the next slot.
[Painful scream]
[Fighter yelling]
JON JON
Nice one, Helen!
KATY
Is he gonna be fighting in one of these?
JON JON
Uh, no, no no no.
These are like, low-level fights.
You're gonna be fighting...
...up there!